what's that guys I killed the [ __ ]
people kid Nana this Jones made these
and he goes be careful with them and my
buddy ate two of them I went to see the
b-52's and he kept dropping glasses cuz
your motor skills oh my I am look oh my
god people forget that and Austin I'll
never forget yelling at the bartender
like how many [ __ ] glasses are you
gonna give this [ __ ] [ __ ] til he put
you out of business I go give him a
plastic cup and he goes I'm out of them
he goes look at everybody everybody was
on Lutz so that when you were when they
were losing the room and it kicked in
every 15 minutes you hear unbelievable
greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
the 22nd of July get your [ __ ] together
the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by for hymns calmness let
me tell ISM with age comes wisdom
but getting old the clothes don't be a
downer in one area specifically if you
know what I'm talking about
40% of men by the age of 40 struggle
with not being able to get and maintain
an erection why do guys turn to weird
solutions you know they like liquor
store stuff and you know Staver a big
dick cream and all that when they get
turned to science and medicine instead
expensive pills injections where no man
wants an injection you don't need that
in your life all right
be wise checkout hymns for hymns calm is
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men and right
now today you could try hymns today for
one month for five dollars enjoy what
are you talking about five hours five
hours I'll give you a month two hymns
for five hours will get you started for
just five bucks while supplies last
prescription products are subject to
doctor approval and require an online
consultation with a decision who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate see website for full details
and safety information but listen do me
a favor go to forums comm anyway right
now whether it's the hair products where
it's the skincare whether it's a sexual
wellness they got you covered and you
could try hymns for one month for five
hours go to try hymns for four hymns
calm the church will also want to
welcome Dollar Shave Club as you guys
know from the beginning we've been
McDonald shave club since day one I love
it every month I got a box in the mail
with all the essentials raises
toothpaste shampoo the works with Dollar
Shave Club you get everything you need
at a fair price now right now today you
can put the quality of Dollar Shave Club
products to the test all right they're
gonna give you the ultimate starter set
which has basically everything you need
for an amazing shower close shave and
clean teeth the best part is you could
try the set for five hours again it's a
five hour Monday on the Church of what's
happening now all right so do yourself a
favor go to Dollar Shave Club club.com
slash Joey
after that the restock box ships regular
size products I have regular prices but
for today get your ultimate starter set
for five hours at dollarshaveclub.com
slash church Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal you steal my [ __ ] sunshine
thank you very much for taking the time
scheduling are you doing the talks the
whole thing I have a lot of interesting
people that come through here you're a
very interesting cat the beauty of it is
that you and I come from the same kind
of savagery you said something or we're
talking you said that we're talking
about going to prison and you said the
main thing I wanted to hear you said I
always know I can make money let me ask
you a personal question did you have a
paper route as a child of course again
America you think I'm [ __ ] lying to
you [ __ ] to learn how to have
you have a paper route shoot yourself
and of course of course that was what
part of my stories I my first thing was
going out door-to-door knocking on doors
to deliver papers all eight years old
absolutely different side our house I
did it two years my mom was so obsessed
with growing this paper out my mom made
me
sell it to someone else so I had to sell
to the upstairs neighbors like me my
first profits $75 I thought was the
richest kid in town right so we're tired
at the age of 10 but didn't last long in
11 I started shoveling driveways at the
snows we used to [ __ ] snow so much
back in it there Matt right before Al
Gore invented global warming right you
still like crazy you just went out with
a shovel it's knocking off your doors 20
bucks driveway and if I push you out
that's another ten yeah we're coming
back with two shovels bury you like it's
[ __ ] Siberia they won't get your car
out to 2008 each good the [ __ ] yeah I
could tell from your interviews and just
reading a lot about your feet when the
book came out that the main thing is
you're a [ __ ] sales I am a Selvam we
sell from beginning to end you know that
Pacino movie is it'll always be selling
mmm that is what we do is that when my
sleep I sell it because nothing happens
until you start something selling is
everything you're just a regular [ __ ]
Momo you know I'm saying until you go I
think people don't realize they think
selling is just a Salesman it's the
furthest thing from the truth you know
just doesn't that what you do business a
personal you're always trying to get
your ideas your points of course to go
yeah it's communication call right
without the ability to communicate
what's on your mind in an effective way
you're going through life like barely
alive that's what I think what was the
job that made you realize you were a
real salesman no whatever the [ __ ] you
know what meat and seafood door-to-door
was the first real big sales job where I
would go knocking on doors cold calling
home to home business to business and
selling him you know boxes of frozen
meat and fishing I just broke the
company record the first day by a
country mile never look back no sure was
the company record if you don't mind me
this uh they were average tell you
averaging like five boxes per day my
first day they gave me 35 boxes of meat
in the truck I sold all 35 boxes I
almost sold woman in the truck all right
and then and that first week I sold 240
boxes I think the average production was
like 30 for the cows blow I blew away
the company record how long did you sell
me for so I worked for this guy for
about four weeks and then I start I own
me company said one of myself of these
mooks for rights like you know they have
a ton
food in the freezer sigh stomach because
before that I told Isis blanket the
blanket on Jones Beach that's amazing I
heard yeah but that was hard work that
wasn't really sales you know I'm saying
so when you asked about what was the
first sales job was really meat and
seafood right that's oh yeah yeah so you
would wake up in the morning go to the
Greek to distribute a story of Queens
right load up four barrels what cool
white staff Urkel's with cherry lemon
cherry lemon lemon ice kale a lemon and
Marino's Marino's ship which is
fudgesicles Milky Way Snickers fully
loaded cool it cost me 22 bucks I blow
it out and out for a hundred thirty
bucks so fourth date at 19 let me tell
you 1978 that's a lot how old are you 16
16 yeah didn't give a [ __ ] they were
[ __ ]
I was amazing it was you know it was
amazing I'll take the may thought it
wasn't the girls was amazing it was that
he got singles so you how much for ours
that was the best part of it yeah when
you woke up in the morning do you think
of [ __ ] or making money for it
everything I've done was a [ __ ] in my
life everything single thing when you
open your eyes and say God thank you for
giving me another [ __ ] day it's time
to make money yeah [ __ ] somebody in the
ears it's time to make money so I could
[ __ ] Sony yes beautiful that's it I'll
be honest with ya you know you have
golden now like I don't quite know right
I got a lovely lovely wife who's the
best ever been married but yes that was
my every I love the women since I was
all of women when I was five years old I
have a stump the scar to prove it I was
being chased by some little girl and
nursery and I ran into a brick wall just
like that I cracked open mike sixteen
stitches on with my eye all right never
since that it's been downhill you know
you you made it quote that I I don't
quote you but I try to portray it as
much as I can and tell people that Green
is not good right you know ambition is
good but passion yeah passion look when
you were selling meat beef would you do
it I mean you just love it you love
getting up in the morning and that's
[ __ ] challenge of clothes on a mother
[ __ ] that challenge of the guy going I'm
not interested hold on wait let me tell
me it helped me out
tell you eat a month you know that
[ __ ] challenge of opening that
[ __ ] door you know ru how we every
daily call that chick come on suck your
dick yeah boyfriend
practice your was I'll tell you the
first you keep saying no but now you
keep getting getting better ik listen
come over and suck my dick I can't I
have a boyfriend just come over for a
while look at pictures I'll show you
pictures of pugs whatever you know
whatever I've always been so well like I
say [ __ ]
I have a boyfriend's that is very dear
they're not interested right there you
go my job was always when I first got on
the phones I was taught if they they
gotta buy from you either they're gonna
die who change their [ __ ] number or
shoot themselves but they're gonna buy
from you and you at first when you start
selling you get discouraged and somebody
hangs up on you my dick gets hard mmm
what a [ __ ] hangs up on me
that's the guy I'm on himself I'm gonna
call him till he dies jumping off a
building [ __ ] dies I got a lot of
[ __ ] for that I was um here's twenty
three four came out I I made this
statement I said you don't [ __ ] hang
up that phone to the customer buys or
dies and it got printed in Forbes
magazine and it was all I was really I
mean it was I got a lot of [ __ ] before
is a magazine for greedy [ __ ] like
that wanna make money so to say that
[ __ ] statement it's time yeah when you
going to sell anything shoes my
sister-in-law called me last Tuesday two
weeks ago she's like ah I'm getting a
job now my sister-in-law and her
daughter good so don't get confused with
that Southern drawl
thank you so much my niece is the number
one sales I mean those people that come
to you out of the vacuums kirby know the
other one I like oh I am [ __ ] when
your house burns down here are your
grandmother had cancer and she dies they
gotta clean the walls you know she'll
come over and sell your paint job like
my niece got a sudden drawl and she's
put some on on right you know not the
biggest hits and she rip your eyeballs
out she'll rip your [ __ ] eyeballs out
and now the mother is out there in the
workforce and she's making appointments
yeah for [ __ ] sure nothing more deadly
than mother-daughter team oh yeah so
she's making appointments to she call me
she's like I'm having
I'm at work can you help me and I call
her what's that [ __ ] guy that we all
learned from what's the cells in the
fertilized eggs eggs eggs Ziggler was
great Oh Zig Ziglar was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I call his
eggs egg Lois ocean again she's got the
record of a ratio the appointment too
close she's breaking the records and
appointments but these [ __ ] Gentiles
are busting their boss you got put a lot
more action into your into your pitch
and she's like are you reading from the
pitch and she goes yeah I always read
from the pitch and I had my own stuff I
said you're breaking the office record
she goes first month they can't deal
with me she goes I made one of the other
girls quit she thought she was hot [ __ ]
blah blah blah I go tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves
as long as you're selling who gives a
[ __ ] what you do there you go that's my
world you gotta keep [ __ ] selling
that's what they teach you that the
number-one rule of a [ __ ] boiler or
more is you gonna call them till they
hang up or they die or they buy buy a
die why do you think certain people are
like selling is natural for them cuz
selling is not natural for me that that
makes me uncomfortable all right the are
selling Oh communication what makes you
control a lot of people of everything
convince somebody of something not even
just convincing but we need when they
say no like be like okay I don't want to
bother them like the idea of sell until
they either buy or die that's how do you
become a good self I train salesmen
listen I mean it makes you become hungry
you know listen it starts with desire
now alright if you if you don't the
desire then it's not for you but if you
have a desire anyone can learn to close
but you have to want it the office is
your listen you're not come for that you
know what my suggestion to you is don't
be in sales right but yourself but that
being said you still have to know how to
get your point across as you move
through the world you live a
disempowered life so you know it's not
if you don't want to convince someone of
a buying a [ __ ] vacuum cleaner but
what do you having problems getting laid
well there you go knows what it is
you have to convince people of things
every [ __ ] day negotiation I even
might the toughest seller ever close was
my wife seriously right yet had a hunt
her down lands like a freakin yeah I was
like a almost close to a stalker with
our okay it was pretty close it's like a
fine line you know I'm saying but the
point is is that you know it's not just
it you think it's selling this he's
talking hard sales right sale selling is
in everything you gotta be a pastor
selling your congregation a lawyer
selling a jury a teacher selling the
kids on the value of education I'm mom
and dad selling their kids on the value
making and selling maturity a guy's
everything sales is everything you don't
every winter yes Harry's a friend of
mine wrote the rest right Terry tells us
sir how he broke into Hollywood without
his ability to communicate and sell and
persuade you would never been and he's a
brilliant guy he rhymes take ten
brilliant people with the same level of
talent you know who's gonna win out the
guy who can't communicate sell explain
his ability to close to so you get it
what's what's the value so I think you
have a negative accurate to what's
selling and you know you can confuse
that if you don't think of it
differently think of as communicating
effectively right well I'm not negative
about it I wish I was better at it but
you can get better at it
well then with the worry why do you
think you guys came so naturally to
because some people will natural born
closes they're all like every for every
Joey Diaz in Jordan Belfort there's a
million people who struggle with it but
the beauty is is that you could teach
anyone to become a successful
salesperson right I'm not saying I'm
gonna make them into me or him but I
promised this I could take any person
that wants it and make them good enough
so it doesn't hold them back in life
that's the point it's I was a [ __ ]
about it at first I didn't like it
either no I think that I would be lying
if I said that I love the rejection I
think anyone likes rejection but to me I
reframe it in my head as a game alright
so the first day I went out I was
trained in that meat business I watched
the guy knock on 50 doors and strike out
and the guy put his head down and lost
his state of certainty and I'll never
forget that really impacted me and I
would for me it was like a bum market on
doors I'll pick it no one's by I am just
[ __ ] I said I am NOT gonna [ __ ] stop
but from my own personal [ __ ]
standard until I get someone I know that
look at it this way right if I know my
racial saying oh if I make 200 calls you
know over time you keep track right
I make 200 calls a day I'll close ten
people just making up a number right so
every time someone says no I just made
money cuz I know what that's worth the
[ __ ] is that yeah I get paid for nosey
yes this doesn't matter it's a numbers
game I've been you understand I'm
wounded - a punk as you meet well thank
you I'm like hey thanks for [ __ ]
saying no you're just made 20 bucks off
you doesn't matter who if you said your
numbers game sales that's what people
don't get here's how sales is it numbs
it said [ __ ] is you know it's 11 what
times you can ask your palm in the ocean
the more people you're gonna catch so to
speak right now obviously it also had to
close the deal right because the worst
what happens if you don't have a close
here's what happens to a lot of people
right is that if you can't the worst
thing for any human being is to try to
play that numbers game but even when you
get someone who can but we'll buy you
can't [ __ ] close and then what's the
point of doing it but when you have the
power and you know you possess the
ability to close anyone whose closeable
that does mean you close everyone you
close anyone whose closeable you'll want
to bang away because you know every
single time you pick up the phone where
they say yes no you're making money
that's the point I had a friend you know
when we're all eighteen everybody wants
to go out and get a piece of children
and that's the headache every time he
went out he got a piece of course yeah
that's a that's a I think it would
destroy ultimate self everybody would go
home with their head down and this guy
would always leave with some [ __ ]
skank that was ready to [ __ ] and the
next day he'd show up with Polaroids and
a lighter up his ass you know it was
just and he wasn't either probably
best-looking guy right no yeah it's
unbelievable I know it's not about that
this would be cut and one night long
enough is enough
Here I am with a pocket of blow
quaaludes this that way we talked about
quite his [ __ ] savage but he's over
there closing them with a quarter ounce
of coke with a quarter gram of coke in
his pocket he's closing the hottest
[ __ ] in a bar and I started shadowing
him and he what he what would come out
of his mouth was atrocities against
Milanovic what's that it was like he
could think of it they go
throwing him in jail makes the [ __ ] in
the worst people but he didn't [ __ ]
around and his percentage was higher
when he got through with them they
[ __ ] them because he let them know
right from the start and I would hear
him like listen man she's home y'all
gonna talk until his [ __ ] Jordan guy
will you crazy
I got an ounce of my pocket I put a rock
in you [ __ ] and suck it out and their
faces would turn pale and next thing you
know they would be getting their purses
and leaving or David telling me was a
pig and walk away from him and then all
night he would send them drinks and
apologize to him he had 8 of them
working at one time so one of them was
gonna go home with him he would have
three [ __ ] and now all of them the
opening numbers game all of them he
would tell him I collect coke Rock I
wanna put on you Clinton just want to
put out myself sing your [ __ ] and suck
it off their faces would melt but he
didn't give a [ __ ] he was closing he
closed him at the bar they knew they
were sucking his dick
there was no let's go home and listen to
Burt Bacharach and you know drink and
tell each other stories no well coming
on my house that's tough luck and I
started doing it the first year it
didn't work out too much people called
9-1-1 and [ __ ] like that but now my
percentage is one up yeah yeah and I
don't mean to be rude you know when
you're 24 that's what you live in for is
to go out and pick up women and you know
whatever have a good time but it was the
same thing it was what would he would
just come out of his mouth was [ __ ]
and he needed cocktails though he was
very shy yeah but he was American and
well nothing's better than [ __ ] quail
of that yeah we used to call courage
pills no please please those things
would sink in they'd be tremendous hope
you could do anything before we get to
the Gorilla Biscuits
when when you go to Hawaii and you learn
Hawaiian Kempo there teach you a punch
right I'll say okay you're gonna punch
lean in the head but before they teach
you how to punch him they teach you how
to strike them in the head with a collie
stick then they teach you how to stab
them and the final move is to punch okay
so you learn all four three phases of
that move
you went from selling door to door and
the beach because and then you went so
you went from belly to belly sales
and then you went into a boiler room
what was the difference now between
those two yeah there's no difference a
lot of guys like you and me but I was
shocked when I was in the meat business
and I heard my business was going
downhill wasn't working out right cuz I
made a lot of mistakes and wasn't doing
I was my first time as an entrepreneur
and what happened was my friend had said
oh I heard no people are making money on
Wall Street and he wanted to get a job
there and what years this is 1986 and
now and what happened was he said to me
yeah they I said well what do they do
goes with a cook you know they they get
wealthy people give that I was from a
poor family right you know wealthy
people to give them money and I assumed
so what did you go door-to-door I I
assumed you'd be knocking on people's
doors I was trained in door-to-door
sales he's like no no they call on the
phone I'm like how's that I couldn't
imagine it when I heard about it I was
like what do you mean you use cold goes
here you call on the phone they send
money I was like no [ __ ] way I was
like he goes yeah yeah that was like a
very casual conversation anyway that was
it then you know a business went down
and I hear my car got repossessed and I
heard a story about a kid in the local
area I grew up Bayside Queens right
who's allegedly making a million bucks a
year on Wall Street and he was like the
[ __ ] dork realm I'm like that guy's
making a million dollars ear and I about
a week late I ran into the guy pulled up
in a Ferrari in a nice suit with a hot
chick holy [ __ ] I want the the chick to
suit the [ __ ] car yeah and I said
Michael what do you think is on man no a
broker always tell you if they make
million to last year I'll make two
million and I said to myself well you
probably said to yourself that [ __ ]
can make a million I'll make ten that's
what I said to myself and I went down to
Walshy the next day and answered an ad
in a big firm they were hiring LF
Rothschild and I sold myself a job and
then I would that was the first time I
walked into a Wall Street forum I could
not believe first of all the language
the cursing the [ __ ] [ __ ] Miami was
unbelievable and also they were actually
calling people up randomly from all over
the country that they never met before
and on a phone call people would send in
a million dollars
it was the most shocking thing to me
that it was suspension of this weird not
have believed it if I didn't see it with
my own eyes that was how it was going on
so when I first saw that
like for a moment I said well all our
best it'll be better even door to door
and then I saw the power of the numbers
you can hear on the telephone and I read
hit me and I watched these guys do it
and I was very fortunate I was sitting
there was my desk part like I was
training me was a really good salesman
this guy right Montana and he played by
Matthew McConaughey in the movie and and
I heard him selling holy like that guy's
good and I hear that guy sucks right and
then I had this ability a new it's
almost so sure I was gonna break the
records on Wall Street as a broker and
then my first day was Black Monday when
the market crashed November 17 October
1997 yeah and it went down 508 points
the firm shut down and that was and that
was the beginning of everything so now
when did you once the firm shot this
shot shut down when did you go start
selling in a boiler room so well
theoretically I mean that was boiler
houses too it was a prestigious firm
with all phones and one room is no
difference it was just the same thing
they were doing the exact same thing as
any other phone based room except they
had a fancy name behind it but was this
no difference right so his massive
outgoing telemarketing Lehman Brothers
was doing it massive outgoing
telemarketing from one location
alright guys it was 51 when I was in 50
hours screaming you know and scheming
going wild the same exact [ __ ] right and
then I went and I so when they shut down
I throw our answer at first I mean I let
the side of my book I don't book I
didn't had the right all right those I
went to another firm for a few days in
Jersey your guy the guy you know I
walked into this place I was like what
the [ __ ] was like a mob on [ __ ] walk
and I worked in a three days and I left
they heard me pitch once and they were
so astonished that when I opened up my
mouth to sell because I was like eight
billion times better than any guy in the
room they were like this made me stop
truce or maybe I'll take the stock I
solved some stupid company called
Panther Mountain water park up in the
[ __ ] great gorge area it didn't even
exist probably all right and I they were
just taking this thing public in enemy
always a penny stock right and I wrote
this script and so it's telling the guy
made me stop and it goes everyone listen
to how the sky cells and the next day I
left I couldn't tell I knew something
was wrong was really
and that's right and I want to work at a
small amount firm called the Investor
Center and there and that was where I
walked they heard me pitch in the same
as you saw in the movie same thing they
were like what the [ __ ] are you doing at
a certain way of selling right and and
the rest is history
now I'll slow it down if you won't but
then you know it's the movies pretty
accurate like that yeah no how long did
it take you to get a series seven I
already have my series seven cuz when I
worked at Rothschild I was studying I
work for six months call calling and I
and I tell my 77 yeah what do you think
about cold calling like yellow it's
Frost I was cold calling the folder
called Dean bees Donna Bradstreet Lee so
just list of you know of names of people
or that hang no no business that owned
businesses that would do it back then
and was doing in excess of a million
dollars in sales so it was business
owners right and you just go call 300 or
400 dollars a day and back then believe
it or not I couldn't even I wasn't
licensed and I had to say hello I've mr.
Hanna holding and passed the phone so
for me that was like [ __ ] Chinese
water torture you know to like not be
able to speak and I would just listen to
everyone else and I was like just
running all the language in my hand like
I can't wait to get this I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill I knew it you know and then
when the market crashed it was like all
my hopes and dreams were dashed and like
a micro say I couldn't believe it that
day that wouldn't it was unreal it
really was unreal it was the month but
the reason why I said November 17th I'm
sorry is because I got arrested November
1887 before the market dashed and I was
solving cars at that time right where I
was selling cars in Boulder had a Subaru
dealer was like stealing right okay I
went from detailing cars to selling
cause I took the bust and it was that's
when I became a Salesman because after
that market crash everything died and
there was only two people so in cars it
was me and this guy named Stormin Norman
who left
that was a [ __ ] Savage he was in the
halfway house at the time I hadn't been
arrested yet and I still remember him
telling me dude do you see anything
funny on my body and me going no I and
he would put a hot water bottle in his
he would scotch tape but his mother's
douchebag knows hot water bottles rubber
ones in rubber ones and then he would
have the valve and just the same thing
would come out of his dick because he
was snorting coke all day at the
dealership so he could put the [ __ ]
fake piss in that he would pay like 25
bucks for piss if you were clean like
they would get it from you finally
talked this Christian guy like the
Christian guy would come no no I'm a
Christian leave me alone you finally put
him together son piss the guy was just a
Salesman hmm and that was the first time
I started looking at people like what
the [ __ ] are these guys doing but before
that there was a guy named Artie
Pressler from the Bronx he was a
psychological salesman a killer you know
don't ever let the customer write down
the credit app you fill it out for them
I want them to tell you their life story
and so they get used to the [ __ ]
asking creepy questions
he just had little [ __ ] details and I
loved all those things and yeah I wanted
to be an attorney him but this art this
thing of [ __ ] selling had my dick by
the balls now interesting Matthew
McConaughey did another movie years ago
called one for the money never saw it it
was about these guys aka Stu finding or
out of Long Island and Mike Duffy that
sells sports information on the phone
hmm and it was Pacino and Matthew
McConaughey and their real name were the
slopes I went to one I'm on a Long
Island I worked them boy than alone I
forget what part of Long Island they
were they were from wherever Seinfeld
was from Syosset whether they all went
to the same high school yeah Jericho
high schools yes oh well they all went
to that same high school whatever there
was something in the water over there's
a lot of my guys came from so I said
whatever the [ __ ] and they were they
were falling sales in that sold sports
information what year was this this is I
I got out of prison 89 Massapequa
Massapequa and I went to work for them
from 89 that's when Stratton was always
surprised that I was at 92 selling
sports my hate now is the prime of
Stratton and we would call people you
know Jordan how you doing Joey dear Pete
patello is my name Pete Botello Colorado
sports advisors
why are you making out in the game and
go [ __ ] yourself I am calling back
listen stop knocking off you [ __ ]
taking a beating you're [ __ ] you know
sports betting big now big now now now
I'm thinking of doing Chang's yes
because now that's what and the only
reason why they're making a huge is so
you could go back to work but you got a
serious doesn't gonna turn them into
hedge funds that's what they're doing
with sports gambling right did you hear
that now now that they're gonna put in
New York and cents so they could do
hedge fund gambling so you don't even
know who you're gambling on they place
the bets for you or some [ __ ] oh sure
that's where they're going with
legalized gambling interesting but to
make a long story short I was a I was
not approached directly there was a
chiller chatter going on a Milan town
about a guy who was making a million
dollars a month selling stocks
I knew about stocks how I knew about you
know pornos I know nothing I know
nothing and I kept hearing little Django
I'm selling coke I'm robbing drug
dealers I'm putting but I keep hearing
the jingle of these guys and making
money but now they had often all opened
the stride office in Miami I go to
Colorado and I'm hearing [ __ ] horror
stories ten guys are going down there at
a time and a - coming back to him they
weren't ever rehabs then mm-hmm you just
want to talk to your priest man you know
I got a devil inside of me I can't stop
snorting coke and even quite a little
time probably knew about what the worst
part is what you do when you're high on
coke and so the things that you the acts
that you commit oh my god the brave and
fellated you pretty small like I can't
snort coke and do comedy but you give me
a line of coke and you give me a pitch
can you give me a bunch of phone cards
oh I'll be slower than calling people
come on topics and then sell them then
come back to the finger in the air yeah
so you get your series 7 license when
there's the money start pollinating this
is 87 988 so a the market crashes I
start in 88 is a broker
this company and I best assent I broke
the record straight how much money we
make of this act right no sure 70,000
80,000 a month in the beginning houses a
broker and then after like the fifth
fourth month I start my own firm so
about six months in so I was approached
after 30 days to split by a guy who said
hey you know you're the best salesman
I've ever heard best trainer or salesman
so I was already helping him train some
salespeople there and uh because dude
let's go partners you know and and then
he took me to see a lawyer in Great Neck
right and then went with him and this
and you know to this lawyer and after
the worker goes you don't need this
other [ __ ] guy you know more than
this guy I already been in business and
failed one so much you fail so you learn
how to do business I have really learned
my lesson that had a startup business in
Berlin so I made a decision to start my
own brokerage firm when I was you know
very young and uh in the beginning I was
selling penny stocks right to average
moms and pops and I came up with an idea
and the idea I had was to cross what I'd
seen on Wall Street with snot penny but
$5 stock so it was selling $5 stocks to
the richest 1% of American so what's
happening was on Wall Street they were
call corn the rich people and in these
little firms like that you knew about I
came I did in my auntie Rae gave a call
on average people with little or no
money but selling him 20 cent stock
saying that's 500 bucks right so I watch
guys bring in millions so I came because
I did this middle ground of going up to
the millionaires but selling them $5.00
stocks and it worked so well when I and
but how I invented a system the training
salesman called the straight line and
allowed me to take all these young kids
who couldn't close when I was like one
guy
my junior partner Danny who was a you
know I trained he was great closer the
other guys could not close rich people
had 12 guys I tried everything didn't
work and I came up with this new way of
training people of how to close it just
was like it was such a profound
difference that I could take any person
and make him into a killer sales person
and that was it then that the next month
I made I think probably four or five
million bucks the next month it went
from like it went so fast that I went
from making a million dollars a year to
make him 50 million within six
so well how does it work so what are the
people working for your firm do you get
a percentage of their commission so
there's there's two ways that you make
money nearly three but simply simply put
let's say a stock is trading at six
dollars okay right and the bid is five
and the offer is six that $1 is called
the spread right the so if a broker
sells 10,000 shares at six that's
$60,000 and that $10,000 gap is the
potential Commission so you would split
that 50/50 you would keep five the
brokerage Cape Cod but what the broker
didn't know is I had the stock I owned
it at two dollars so I made three
dollars below the bid that was mine 100%
was mine if I traded right so I had a
supply of stocks and the idea was how do
you get a supply of stock cheap right so
just close the stock Majan you buy a
million she has a stock it's two and you
hold it and the stock goes up to five
you got a three million dollar potential
profit you have to be able to sell it
when I invented the straight line system
I could get these young kids to sell to
a grid call millionaires and they'd
sound like geniuses they could close
them so with that before they could they
couldn't with the regular sale system so
that was like the sort of great
equalizer allowed them to be as powerful
as the top Wall Street broker in terms
of persuasion so once that happened it
just went apeshit crazy because all
these kids who have been working in
7-eleven became master salespeople and
they were making millions a year and I
was making a million a week it was just
crazy and it just grew and grew and grew
and it was [ __ ] insane when did when
did you start going personally crazy
like when how old were you when you 27
26 so 7 it was too much - yeah yeah
listen I come from a really good family
my parents in you know amazing people it
wasn't so it was like I was raised that
way and any stretch I was raised the
opposite you know I think for me it was
that I went into my adulthood with a lot
of like wounds from my adolescence that
I said if I just get rich man I'll have
[ __ ] I sort of played on every
adolescent
ever had and I was so good at closing
and training others did as good as I was
selling I was even better at training
others too close that was my real gift
even woman selling yeah that was easy
but training others and that people
started calling me the king and I
couldn't handle it I was stupid you
stopped believing your own [ __ ] when
you're young right I mean now I'm a
little older and wiser Oakley and it
just you know all of a sudden every girl
wanted to [ __ ] me and and it just was
that I was had her it just was it it was
very difficult for me at 25 or 26 years
old there was that much power and also I
think that you know what happens is a
lot of people you probably seen this in
Hollywood right is that when you're on
when you're struggling to get rich if
you're not feeling good inside you're
like okay well it's okay because you
know I don't have what I want right now
when I get rich and I have everything
they don't feel good so you can make
sense of insecurities you can make sense
of not feeling great about yourself but
what happens when you get everything you
ever wanted in life times a thousand and
you still feel like [ __ ] inside then
what do you do that's what the [ __ ]
real panic sets in and then enter
quaaludes cocaine and [ __ ] massive
amounts of eating bed yes because it
makes me to an animal when I do that
that's I'm a check on [ __ ] ID you I'm
the most normal I really am
I'm thank God I'm sold for 20 plus years
right I love my wife to death she's the
best ever grace one of them all right
you give me a [ __ ] 8-ball
god knows what the [ __ ] I will do I'll
be in a [ __ ] whorehouse eating and
hoping they're in their period cuz I'm
[ __ ] sick and I and by the way anyone
who's a bit of coke god knows what I'm
talking about loose it's not I'm not
crazy you know a Joey
it's crazy something wrong with the drug
it makes you a sexual [ __ ] deviant
and I loved it you know and I [ __ ]
loved it tell him all the time point you
chuckling this is making them puking and
when I'm not gonna swallow you come when
I was right and I'm not I don't have
anything bigger puke that compulsion
doesn't exist in me does not but when I
do it it's like it really I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is
and and I thought
something wrong because everyone else is
doing the same [ __ ] when they're on it
it's crazy like people are getting tied
up the hair and show no a million I want
to be choked small choking Joey hate me
there was a chick I used to snort coke
when Aspen I had to be 23 she was like
29 I would come on the table she would I
would make it suck it through a straw
disgusting
not a friend come on freak a hookers
10,000 of [ __ ] in a glass table while he
could look underneath when he's on
[ __ ] he knows day in the [ __ ] life
I had a friend that came to me in 94 I
looked him straight in the face you
still bang about business it's too
dangerous out there I make him jerk me
off with their feet
he wasn't I can I can understand his
driving and makes perfect sense he
didn't miss a beat that's why I knew he
wasn't lying makes perfect sense but
when did all that what you did all that
1996 his daughter and start start it
started earnest in 1990 and how many is
madness was 70 coming in seven on seven
money Hey eight years old limited money
eight years just calm I gotta deliver it
yes yes kilo [ __ ] around I mean you're
just saying how the guys get it right
from the airport pure right there yeah
at that time but my big thing was
quaaludes I I literally single-handedly
cleaned out every country of quaaludes
like pharmacy we are we were going it's
like you know every country its own
brand of quaaludes right so when the
u.s. made them illegal in the late 80s
the early late 1970s right so when I was
in college they were illegal but you
still they were gone but you must get do
further Aylor drunk for sleeping you
know in the 70s right they made him
illegal but they swept and took a lot of
the supply but you still had them out
there for like a few more years then by
84 most of the real ones were gone but
you could still get like met the seals
from Switzerland Palin and Burma from
Spain you get Norman ox from Germany
manager Xmas I know that was the shootin
package to call Paris blues you know
Paris for hundreds was while Paris
wondrous yeah they were ya know every
type of quail has own little formulation
so some of them what's this here what's
this what yeah
it's kept you really no way open it up
I'll take the seconds this guy's got a
[ __ ] pay there you go I've been
rising my I say what is this a did you
say we're on it's rora
that's still one the FBI swarmed to
Cosby they knew the agent he threw me
the last three of them really that no
that's a that's a mic up oh this is a
bunny follows Lana gazebo what do they
call them a placebo opposition boat okay
yeah my Hollis wedding oh my god oh yeah
three of them I would honestly I'm so
buffers no but one of you I would take
one right now oh no if you gave me a
real quaalude why my wife tied me up so
good great damage because you only get I
would get phone itis they call the four
iyslah I wanted to call ever I love you
I love she unplug all the phones in my
house max why do you man
I love you Olivia when I got this there
were three of them but before my wife
had the baby I hate one of them one
Friday night just just after they all
Pepitone she passed out at eight one and
I was on so much refresh sure I didn't
even know what it was you know I didn't
know what it worked
I love the bottle oh so yeah the [ __ ]
bottle Cheers
take it to your offices [ __ ] never mind
listen so what is this thing now what's
in them it's it's a bacon like that look
at it but it's perfect really it's a
dummy but it's perfect go nine years
it's one of the nicest gifts I've got
please it's a Rolex watch
I want this no that's a show you taking
the time to come in Ian awesome bus so
now when they show it everybody know
this is quite this is vintage by the way
so these this got this label got me in
deep trouble yeah it said cousin I read
I have this experience of the call
crashes right right I took their work
spires they were delayed fuse I [ __ ]
just like me I lost my [ __ ] yeah how
many did that what's the most you ever
did in one night
well I went through a really doing the
day tournament like I saw watch the
movie door Oh time I would take four in
the morning before my Alec get up at
like 6:00 a.m. before my wife so I could
get my first high go up and down before
she [ __ ] woke up and I got really bad
I was probably doing 22 a day 20 22 you
know funny how these [ __ ] jamokes huh
DOP that
well [ __ ] you in 79 whewee Gorilla
Biscuits I still number given my buddy a
quail and tell them be careful he said I
got this Ted speed yeah I saw what a
[ __ ] cracker and a cracked up tents
be I don't Alerus oh no I was you didn't
real you felt coordinated right you
thought you thought you have if you add
together you did and you'd be like just
[ __ ] bouncing off walls but what they
would do is he breaking is only muster
really taking a [ __ ] fall because it
almost like turned you got rubberized a
bit like you get bounced off [ __ ]
walls you wouldn't get hurt that easily
but I'll tell you what I remember in the
long la New York law I expressed a write
on Sunday mornings it was a club called
infinity and that peepers are [ __ ]
crazy night club back then with no
matches we were [ __ ] upstairs just
nuts you see lines of cars smashed up on
the highway but a Sunday morning
everyone came home on ludes thinking
they could drive and just destroyed
their [ __ ] cars remember that when
did you start feeling the heat first the
FCC came back no no it was sec FCC
that's EC SEC yeah here it is Exchange
Commission they came at me early and
like 90 through 94 and I set up with
them and then the FBI came in after and
the COS of money I'd smuggled the switz
alone now in the movie you invite the
feds over to your boat yeah yeah is that
true no they just mailed yeah that's a
good signal that's a great seat yeah
yeah that's something I would do they
want it because what had it phone - you
know I'm the type of [ __ ] take
two Cuellar's and call the FBI office
how you doing you're investigating me
that come on man the purpose that scene
was because you know the the thing was
that Coleman is a friend of mine now the
agents a friend of Mines a good guy and
we speak all the time right and back
then we had this parallel he chased me
for like seven eight years but we never
never saw her so it's not enough in the
for the movies much better for you get
it was a meeting in the middle so may
increase the tension so and then when
did you get arrested
1998 September to come to the house they
can't reproduce not at all they're
incredibly respectful
to me incredibly respectful um I was my
I left the house with my daughter it's
you wanna go to Blockbuster Video I'm a
blockbuster back there right and as I
was pulling out there was a car outside
my ID gates and this some woman goes
excuse me do you know where this road is
and now it's like none other then
another guy jatha I was getting
kidnapped and it's just all stop not
from the FBI and just listen you
probably want to drive back in and drop
your daughter home I was like oh okay
well I appreciate that and I went in
they just they followed me and they
didn't pull any guns nothing they've
walked me in they said listen you know
you are under arrest and uh she's coming
to you into your office and I just
walked in there and they just well they
came in a lot of mothers attend him in
the house they did not pull guns nothing
what would you bail ten million how long
did you sit inside today's and then how
long till you got sentenced oh it's a
long time fears were you I was in were
you broken up no no now wasn't broke but
there's nothing worse i rather been
broke and gone to jail the next day then
the slow descent into [ __ ] hell
that's the worst part of all like yeah
the worst part was it a few years but
you know it doesn't happen quickly you
know the wheels of justice grind snow
they tried them prosecute me quit yeah
yeah that's right that's very rare I
kept playing yeah and playing with fire
in attorneys yeah and it took a long
time and that was like the slow descent
into like and you couldn't restart your
life and it was pretty that was the once
I got out it was like um it was just you
know it's right back up when did you
realize you were going in at one point
you do from day one you were going away
yeah I know so was your attorney telling
me I mean there was no do some media do
some time you know but you know
hopefully your first offense nonviolent
you know and so I figured to a few years
you know and uh and you know we had this
you know I got I got four years but the
eight deductions to the drug program to
go through and anyway of a qualified for
the trucker was me everyone's trying to
get into that I was like they're like
I'm like a tailor-made for right so I
went through the drug got eighteen
months off like that good behavior and
and when I got out you know so like I
was very fortunate because as you as you
know his friend sitting here um
Tommy Chang was my bunkmate from Cheech
and Chong we play put his'n to see we're
in the same settle together so when I
got to jail on wanna sit with Tommy's a
awesome dude should have him on your
pocket
you came on oh you mean it's brilliant
really smart right yeah brilliant guy
right so in time he's like we tell each
other stories and I had them rolling on
the floor and you know by the 3rd and
Isaac did I thought you were full of
[ __ ] but my wife googled you it's all
true because you got to write a book I
was like really it's like you know you
don't think your own life is something
you never know I was like what do you
mean my life's really I thought everyone
sunk yachts and crash planes and did
eight billion drugs and made all my ass
how crazy is that back nothing happened
for me if I told my story I know I was
cracking jokes nothing was happening
because I thought that everybody else
had delivered papers yeah I thought
everybody else sold yeah yeah at the
beach with 25 bucks I just you know I
thought I was just a regular guy me too
well I was a regular I never bought you
but we know we were insane but I I just
I guess I you know when you're living it
you become desensitized your own sadly
right I remember this this this moment
in my life and probably 1996 when I was
living an old Brookville beautiful at
the Gold Coast nicest area in the world
right
mansions everywhere and I'd imagine and
then I put my wife in the car I'm gonna
like driving around like they must all
do ludes right if everyone's doing
glutes and coke
you don't think anyone could live to go
through life sober when you're when you
like that like I it's place of everybody
else was doing what I was doing and to
think back at that moment now is pretty
laughable but that's what you do so when
Tommy said to me you know I've never
heard of anyone living this sort of life
like you've lived as like lots a lot
come from Tommy Chong I but so that gave
me some so I started writing and Tommy
would help me and gave me a little
couple pointers and uh and I fortunately
was able to crack the code for writing I
taught myself to write and I started
writing and then people liked it and
then Leo and Marty uh as soon as the
book was done the rest is history
the wolf of Wall Street yeah I can't
remember the story why to rent this
movie I'll tell you something incredible
about Martin Scorsese that
you can't quantify to put your finger on
it but somehow he created a movie that
will go down forever it's a generational
movie and I don't think anyone Rio was
right because Leo is the one who
attached himself to it and was Leo's
passion project and Leo said to me
just trust me buddy Marty has to II need
Marty to direct this movie goes there's
a lot of the Ridley Scott Lord the Rings
line I was getting frustrated as Marty's
very slow you know it was many many
years I sold them the book in 2006 mid
2006 and it's in 2006 right and it was
like it takes forever and then he's like
just trust me let me get Marty he was
right I mean marty was able with Leo
force as well as brilliant but he's got
a special talent for telling the story
and I think what it is you're it is okay
it is that he doesn't tell a story with
judgment the one thing I hate about the
movies I'm sure you hate this to me
everywhere I'm you all ain't this right
I don't be [ __ ] moralize dude don't
tell me how I should feel when I watch
something let me [ __ ] watch it and
come play on conclusion I don't want a
morality tale all right just tell me
what happened to let me draw the
morality from it and Marty put it up on
screen as it was for better or worse
without you know and some say he glamour
yeah he didn't go out it was glamorous
it wasn't glamourizing it was glamorous
and that's what he did and also his dark
and disgusting and he put that up too
that's what I enjoyed about the movie
the most it's real I enjoyed the movie I
really didn't literally put it up there
with Goodfellas great movie it was great
review tell me what's my favorite part
of that movie is he took me there
exactly I had to go to the bathroom
take two bong hits and take a half a
xanax he took me there
yeah minded me of my own of that time
you know I told you that I had the same
yeah they came they said do you want to
sound on the phone I mean no I was gonna
give it a try but when I went down and
looked and felt it didn't feel right
something just didn't feel right it felt
like it was too [ __ ] easy and it was
III I find it difficult to understand
the world the way it is that is some I
don't I think
[ __ ] crazy what's happened in the
last five years for this world with
political correctness and an older [ __ ]
is like the it's just I don't know I
just think that it's a it's a lot worse
than it was in terms except differ as it
is but I just think it's ridiculous
what's going on right now with like all
of a sudden like every word has to be
watched that you say everyone's [ __ ]
sensitive and everyone like everyone's
been you know me too or whatever - hey
is this gross I'm gonna regret yeah and
I'm gonna get immigrant dogface New York
City my parents immigrant said the less
Israel no no I'm your France and Russia
I thought you were Jewish I am but yeah
but France fridge Russia Aurora I
thought that Oh human and when I came
here my first day my mother said to me
in 66 or 68 or fourth time I got the ps1
66 is like look you don't talk English
outside the house and in now she gonna
talk Spanish I don't want you doing that
me too me too routine out there I don't
want them to look at his weak let's
start thinking about it's great I'm not
sticking up for nobody
I'm not political I got felonies I do
not want to [ __ ] go to jury duty I'm
not sticking up for anybody in
particular I was growing up on and I
swear to God until 85 86 if I was at a
cafe and you and your mother were
talking Israeli for more than five six
minutes in New York somebody would come
up to you know Oh English yeah and you
would go I think at the butler whatever
the [ __ ] you're saying they would go go
back to your [ __ ] country I mean it
was well known you know III yeah again
and I think that it was just a statement
in New York it's misunderstood it's
misunderstood what it means I didn't get
offended when I was a no you say go back
to your own conscience doesn't mean
first I love immigrants we all but come
legally and also appreciate for being
here but I don't want anyone to leave
and go back but if you hate the country
you should leave the country why the
[ __ ] should you be if you don't love the
country then you get the [ __ ] out and go
back to your own country but I'm not
because anyone that anyone I don't care
what call you were you from if you want
to be here and love this place for me my
doors open in not my house but you know
has come here and enjoy this country
everything has the
but you want to come here and hate on
this country get the [ __ ] out that's my
point
I don't care what you want everyone
should be welcome but when you come
issued you should learn to speak the
language okay you should pay [ __ ]
taxes you should [ __ ] be redundant
you know I don't it really bothers me
the way they depress is twisting the
message because you know the Trump says
stupid [ __ ] I'll say he miss phrases
himself some funds but he doesn't that
his meaning is clear his means he's not
saying that people who are law who will
love the countrymen should leave the
country if you hate this country why are
you here very different I think all
immigrants have the right to come here
legally all right and I welcome the fun
my parents immigrants but you know it's
just a silly it's something odd is going
on he's very strange going on right now
right I'm not sticking up patron I'm
just saying that he says stupid [ __ ]
that he makes mistakes he said I didn't
take it personally a day and I've know
it doesn't mean that right exactly 6th
Avenue in that statement to be made it's
manipulated by the press for political
reasons ok and you know he's he said the
unfunny comic Trump anyone else could
say what he says it would be ok he says
it just tries people crazy I think
that's some level he's doing it on
purpose to fun at this point he's just
looking to push people's be gotta be at
this point look he's looking to do it
because I'm like his I'm like oh my god
you mean you're gonna really fall for
this [ __ ] that he that he said you guys
are really gonna react secret roll the
news cycle again are you that stupid
that you're really are gonna write about
this
it's so obvious he just said [ __ ] and
they just go nuts and like it's like
it's stupid at this point you know we
just turned to me the numbers that were
thrown out in the movie were just so
mind-blowing and I I'm not a fan of
Trump personally but can you explain the
power that that amount of money gives
you like when you were on the plane and
you got tied down like like maybe not
even for Trump but just like what that
amount of money would be it doesn't it
doesn't okay it's a misconception it
gives you it gives you power till it
doesn't you know it gives you power that
I could fall down and so little pick me
back up
it gives me power if I break a small law
I can buy my way out with great
attorneys all right but I you know when
you you know nowadays especially we live
in a different world I don't care who
you are you know the big you are they
gun for you right now and everything you
did becomes I have a lot of close
friends and in the last year's been
really they've taken major falls from
graces but things they've done or
allegedly done thirty years prior and I
have a problem with that all right
and I have a daughter who I love to
death through but you know I have a
problem with people being choose for
things that are not provable from 30
years ago this is just a gross and
disgusting and it's not fair it's on
American that's why I say whatever I did
30 years ago no I just put it out I
don't give a [ __ ] whether it's robbing
one time I wanted to a car while I was
10 when I [ __ ] love called on the
grammar book come on I just wanted to
shoot the the many saints of Brooklyn
and I was in uh it was Ridgewood
Brooklyn well we were shooting and as I
went in they had a [ __ ] carve out
that Abe Lincoln went to I think when he
[ __ ] was in New York that for a short
stint I mean and for somebody else who
would have saw that they would have gone
crazy my dick got hard my dick got hard
and the next day look at this [ __ ]
car though look at this Carvel Wow
it's a Shack in Ridgewood right there no
it's not even it's not even it was like
three blocks before you get the ridge
come on
it was [ __ ] old so the next day I see
a Bank of America looking from the side
the next day I'm in my [ __ ] trailer
and I go why am I doing this trailer let
me go take a walk on this Myrtle Avenue
and I didn't walk fifty [ __ ] feet and
once they're waiting for Papa
a brand new car belt like the new state
of the art ones I saw two Chinese chicks
in there making fuckness shakes on like
I would have a problem because they
wanna lose an investment they decide the
old guy with the missing foot where we
were kids he had the Carvel because he
loved carve out his wife the kids were
fat one kid lost an eye when he was
eight from eating so much Carver
it wasn't an investment it's all good
now if you go to the car vow in Santa
Monica and called the city it's an
investment you walk in there you feel
like you're getting raped for 80 for a
cold yang then you go to the guy you
from New York there's like man I'm from
Iowa you don't have the right to sell
come bail you gotta earn that right
before your fight the part
it's like lemony I said of Corona yeah
lemon I said you know there's just
certain things so I went in there and I
go the lady comes up to say can I help
you you know me I open up with a double
column vanilla chocolate and color with
sprinkles and whipped cream oh yeah I
was telling them and I get a chocolate
shake very thin and then dip it and then
eat it that's how I grew up together
there's a place in the village might
door three to called
two gay guys saying it's a gay ice piggy
ice cream guys how cool I was [ __ ]
good by the way they do the Carvel's
like I thought it was gonna be something
different throws me like scoop ices and
she's like oh so good big guys come
right and walk in the [ __ ] car Bell
did I [ __ ] that's the bet and see
they're the owners you get it it's like
a [ __ ] family thing I hate family
right no it's their [ __ ] thing yeah
very cool line up around the block for
big ice cream otherwise 800 pounds it's
a [ __ ] real thing it's real is on
rollerskates the foot the diet exactly
dining car alone and they keep eating
called Bell even in spite of all no
matter exactly fact I bought the
milkshake I ordered a large and I looked
at the weight watcher points and I go
[ __ ] but I just get a small it took
three subsided and I threw it away but I
did buy two things of flying saucers for
the girls on the Senate caught ball
trucks it's oh my god
Oh mr. Softee mr. Sauvage off thing
right now is my [ __ ] too so mm when you
get arrested when do you turn yourself
in for 2003 for when you come on mm in
the 2005 how are you feeling
ripped in good shape I came out in
really good shape and with em with a
book a hundred and fifty pages of a book
I threw it away but I taught myself to
write so I learned this skill while I
was away and I came out and started
writing what were you thinking about the
outside when you came out what were you
thinking
we're gonna use one of my kids now I
didn't care about I had never worried
about that at all and how old is your
daughter that you speak not she's 26
but she's the one for me she's graduated
from grad school at my you she's uh
really successful at my son's a rapper
mother son's businessman works in me if
four kids all together just with their
first wife to Oz in the movie she's my
second wife okay I have two and then I
have a stepson with my current who's
like my own son there's the same thing
and uh so he works for me and I'm very
old my second kids is he a rapper and
hip hop and he's gonna be famous he's a
really talented and he's awesome
all my kids are I'm very fortunate but
for me when I came out it was all about
my kids that came out I didn't speak to
an adult probably for me more or less
for like about a year i holed up in a
little tiny apartment in Playa del Rey I
had no money and I started writing that
book and my kids would come over and
they'd say daddy's writing you and I and
I said to my daughter I'm gonna write a
best-seller and become famous you know I
said it duck said I never believed
things I was scared I wouldn't finish
so I told puss I wouldn't let her down I
said I'll never let my daughter down so
I used it as a way to motivate myself
especially what you told my ex-wife that
I really had a [ __ ] do it right so I
have no choice but to finish this book
that told my daughter I was gonna be a
famous writer because I was scared I
would never finish I would I was so I
did that to motivate myself and I
finished the book in about ten months
but by the time I was on page 12 I had
sent it to an agent I just you know knew
very casually and he read the page he
was like he looked he said did you write
these yourself I was like yeah he said
holy [ __ ] because I thought Tom Wolfe
had written them because I had modeled
Tom Wolfe I'd learned to write like Tom
Wolfe or at least try to and he goes
right 10 more pages I wrote 10 more and
I sent in those pages he goes stop
everything you're doing yours you don't
understand what's about to happen to
your life his name is Joel caller I said
what he goes you know you don't know
because this is gonna be the biggest
book because Leonardo DiCaprio's gonna
play you and Marty Scorsese
I swear to god this Edison in on page 22
of the book I thought he was out of his
mind
so I just literally didn't work I stay i
holed up in my in his little apartment
for about ten 11 months and I wrote
1,200 pages and I and Random House and
they sold it to rights it got bought by
Random House right where they add to the
30 pages so I had money and you know I
had some money raised to live and I went
through seven edits on the book to go
from $1,200 528 pages and and yeah and
as soon as the magic was done the fioor
the first guy to latch on wasn't leo he
was second Terry winter miss Terry once
Terry for those Sopranos right and
Bullock ever once he said I have to
adapt this everyone leo is like almost
son Leo came on board and why he came on
board and then then came to slow Marty
hell cuz body's just slow you still talk
to Terry Terry I just texted him today
by the way Tom I say I love ya I said to
the text today forget about me from
these are Nocturne he's an amazing
Terry's really she's riding this thing
now he's so easy to wait he's such a
great writer he took TJ English's book
and we put it into I have not read the
script but I have heard the stories
little apple TV bought it so apples the
breaking his balls too much Fidel enough
to Dow some shits go how do you say
about Terry Terry's brilliance I know he
has no ego he I he loved my book and he
took my book and somehow formulaic ly
turned it into a movie script he didn't
try to make it Terry winters version of
my book he took it and she's a brilliant
guy with no ego and his first draft was
perfect the movie that you saw was like
his first draft more or less it's
unbelievable so and then Leo came on
sand once that happened that was a
unbelievable turning point in the movie
from in my life because once Leo and
they all came on what was announced
publicly that it got bought out so then
Random House immediately exercised an
option for a second book so I wrote this
part too to the book and then what
happened was they greenlit the movie in
2007 then the writers
break it and it got delayed this five or
six years I was devastated at the time
because I said oh my God Almighty the
best thing ever because what happened
was during those five years I became
wealthy again I made back my money and
started speaking teaching sales around
the world by the time the movie came
back around Leo came to us what happened
how did you get rich guys I told them
and they changed the entire third act in
the movie to have my comeback in there
the first version didn't have my
comeback and I'd be ending up in jail so
they ended up with me on stage speaking
it was humble so it turned out to be
this unbelievable thing I think I think
to learn that you could change your life
story while they were making it I
changed my own life stories never if you
like to change your story do you put one
foot in front of the other and work your
ass off you know you're a dangerous man
and it's funny when I went to Wikipedia
you know I went to your website and
stuff and not to embarrass you nothing
like that it's not my style I'm just
saying this because this is how I feel
you and I share a certain bond and it
was that it said celebrity that's worse
- but what life doesn't know is that's
how you want it favorite in fact the
best work you do is when you know
[ __ ] underdog you're like Joe Montana
when Dallas the Dallas watch did the San
Francisco give it a point in 82 like
we're gonna [ __ ] up Joe Montana and Joe
Montana said [ __ ] you're coming into my
house you always live your life like
it's your house I'm looking at a rich
wife really rich she's my partner
the partners but she was rich before you
mean now okay the partners right I get
what you saying
no no really bought no I know she really
started my business means you put her
own money and to start the business and
and she works me every day and and I'm
very fortunate but she's brilliant
so her partner's yeah no you were lucky
man I don't like he made [ __ ] I
mean when I read all that stuff like I
read about you first somebody mentioned
you somewhere and I
did not read your book I've seen the
movie three or four times but I've not
read the book now you gonna force me to
read the [ __ ] I think it's written in
a way that you will yeah yeah yeah
you'll I love everything about you
well it's not no it's written in this
voice and you'll like it you know what's
with the crazy thing about anybody give
you any [ __ ] now what happened over
those years with now did you you did
your time yeah did your thing I know you
have you look happy
ya know what some like me you don't
really you know you know do you really
believe what you read in the newspapers
you know better than that no no it's all
nonsense so like I know when I got out
of prison I felt weird for a while I
felt weird you know it was a point so
that's what I'm trying to get from you
what I'll tell you what it is it's not
that I in the beginning when I first
went my life became public again and
they would say things about me that I
stole this money and it would make me
feel bad inside it would because I'm a
good person and I and I regretted doing
light in and I got to a point
well a I've done so much good in the
world in the West and years it helped so
many millions of people but that's not
doesn't never wolfs Eddie but I start to
realize that no one gives a [ __ ] about
it except a few journalists that's it
a few idiotic journalist them keep
fighting by the way I appreciate the
hating you know why because it makes me
a lot of money the haters because it
increases my engagement online so oh you
[ __ ] hands keep on hating me because
you took pour it on because what you
start a conversation my fans can react
and then it creates engagement and boom
it's awesome so I don't present it but
here's the thing I made mistakes we all
make mistakes and you know it's what you
do after you make mistakes that's how
you defined and I think I've defined my
life in a in a very empowering way that
in a way that empowers many millions of
people around the world and probably
more than hundreds of millions of people
are empowered by my life story thanks to
the movie and the work I do in terms of
training and and and and teaching about
entrepreneurship so I think that's the
gift I give the world is that the movies
funniest great awesome is great to sort
of everyone but the gift I give the
world is the ability to understand that
matter where you are in life
it doesn't matter you can come back as
long as you want to work hard learn
strategy it's gotta be strategy right
well right yeah yeah you gotta know what
to do right but if you want everything I
move is strategy every [ __ ] move on
it yeah every time I leave the [ __ ]
house it's thought-out and it doesn't
happen when people don't get that and of
course I was whenever I see this as a
person you would think that is it what
it's [ __ ] strategy and hard work and
hard work the intersection of that and a
little bit of luck and the harder I work
the luckier I get lucky you get there
yeah brother it's been a pleasure my is
good my pleasure I'd loved any of my
show as well I just wanted you would be
great my dad to love you just contact me
and I go down there will speak I live on
the beach you'll love it we have what
yeah I'm on the ocean yeah I was just
down in Huntington I took my family down
there fourth of July weeks yeah and I
you know I love it down there it makes
you you know growing up in Jersey in New
York I read every impression you got a
California chicks on the beach with
bikinis and then you get here you find
yourself living in [ __ ] Hollywood and
you never go to the [ __ ] beach until
one day you go [ __ ] this I'm gonna start
to go to the beach more and that's what
I've sworn you and you've been an
inspiration to me I think you are an
inspiration to a lot of people and I
want people to know that second chances
are [ __ ] real you just got to do
something with the [ __ ] hang out
don't forget you filthy [ __ ] I'll be at
the DC Lincoln Theatre August 9th that's
all I got for you right now go to the
website and that's it and that's that
now for a word for our sponsors again I
want to thank Jordan Belfort for being a
tremendous [ __ ] guest I want to thank
the [ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] on a
Monday morning cuz you're gonna have the
weaker you goddamn life before we leave
I want to talk to you about a little Sun
the dollar shape the Church of what's
happening now is sponsored by the Dollar
Shave Club I've been at Dollar Shave
Club member for years you guys know that
and I love it every month I got a box in
the mail with all the essentials raises
toothpaste shampoo the works it's a
no-brainer
no more running over to the drugstore to
pay premium for things you use every day
with Dollar Shave Club you get
everything you need at a fair price and
Dollar Shave Club is way more than just
raises all right
they got you covered from head to toe
everything you need to shower they got a
shave style your hair brush your teeth
and even wipe your butt with one wipe
Charlies you got to keep that muffler
clean at summer time but that's not all
smelly throwing some sea spray deodorant
frizzy hair
they got pomade hair cream hair gel and
half pace you got no excuses you got a
hot date
they even got cologne and you can try it
all with that specialized route kids or
the combination that works for you plus
they'll keep your stocked on a schedule
that works for you whether that's once a
month or a few times a year and right
now you can put the quality a Dollar
Shave Club to the test by going a
dollarshaveclub.com slash Church you
understand me listen I think that the
ultimate starter set that basically has
everything you need for an amazing
shower close to shave and clean teeth
and the best part is you can try each
set for five dollars five dollars and
after that they restock box to restock
box ships regular size products at
regular prices but get your ultimate
starter kit for five dollars at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Church CH you
are CH that's dollarshaveclub.com slash
Church the church is also brought to you
by for hems comm hims connects you with
real licensed doctors and FDA approval
pharmaceutical products to treat Edie
Joey what are you talking about listen
when age comes wisdom but you're getting
old and it can be a downer because I'm
from time to time you know what I'm
talking about 40% of men by the age of
40 struggle with not being able to get
and maintain the stick of death why do
you guys turn to weird solutions you go
to a liquor store buying a bottle of
tequila let me try these bills when they
can when you could turn to medicine and
science expensive pills injections where
no man wants an injection
give me a breather listen as far as I'm
concerned I knocked up my wife at 50 the
helmets working fine but from time to
time in the middle of it sometimes you
drift and the helmet gets a little soft
be wise checkout hymns for hymns calm is
a one-stop shop for hair loss
skincare and sexual wellness for men all
right hims connects you with real
licensed doctors and fda-approved
pharmaceutical products to treat he D
see results where other treatments fall
short listen stop worrying about
multiple and doctor visits no painful
injections and it's easy you answer a
couple of questions about your medical
history your chat with a doctor for a
confidential review if you're approved
by the doctor BAM the products are
shipped directly to your door being
being your best means performing your
best its erectile without the
dysfunction it's hard made easy saying
hello to your little friend listen try
him for a month for five hours we're
gonna get you started for just five
hours while supplies last prescription
products are subject the doctor approval
and require an online consultation with
a physician who will determine a
prescription that is appropriate for you
who's better than for him is calm nobody
see website for full details and safety
information go to for hims calm right
now and you're not gonna be sorry
alright so I gave you a dollar shave
club and for hims calm I'm taking care
of you I'm watching you don't forget
August ninth Lincoln Theatre Washington
DC August 13th majestic be the Dallas
August 14th the Aztec theater in San
Antonio I don't know if this tickets
left go take a look I don't know what
the hell to tell you right have a great
week enjoy the podcast wash your [ __ ]
it's gonna be a hot want to drink water
[ __ ] uncle Joey here stay black
have a great [ __ ] week kick this
[ __ ] melee a little something
for meeting you guys alright